[Music]
coming up a special report on a social
media sensation a ballerina born without
arms
but the world of professional ballet
refuses to accept victoria
we report on her battle to do ballet
this is true for you what didn't make me
give up was the people who were always
by my side especially when i decided i
wanted to dance
[Music]
hi there our special report is coming up
but first imagine being a big boss and
as the 359 people you're in charge of
148 or 41 of them want you to quit your
job you're talking about the prime
minister right yeah he can't be feeling
too popular well a big political drama
is only one of a few big stories we've
been investigating
so the prime minister faced a vote of
confidence
this is when members of his own
political party conservative mps vote on
whether the pm should stay or go
boris johnson won the support of 211 mps
with 148 voting against him
i can announce that the parliamentary
party does have confidence
it means he can continue in his job
without another challenge for a year
the vote took place because at least 54
conservative mps handed in letters
saying they no longer supported the
prime minister
that's because of what became known as
partygate
so the prime minister has been under
pressure to quit after investigations
revealed he broke lockdown rules by
attending gatherings that shouldn't have
been allowed
he may still have his job but he's
clearly lost a lot of support from his
own party
did you see how liverpool football fans
were tear gassed by french police at the
champions league final in paris of the
week well uefa which oversees the
football in europe has apologized to
liverpool supporters
yeah so the match was delayed by more
than 30 minutes with officers forcefully
holding back people trying to enter the
stadium
uefa say that they're now investigating
what led to the frightening and
distressing events
aarov was there to watch the final with
his dad hi arav hi
so what happened that night
when we got through the first checkpoint
we saw french police chasing liverpool
fans we arrived at the gate and there
was so many people cubing up we waited
there for a couple of hours and then we
finally got at the front of the key and
then french police sprayed tear gas and
i heard my dad
say cover your eyes and i did it a
little too late and then my eyes and
face started burning i was very confused
i told my dad why aren't the police
helping us shouldn't they be helping us
and protecting us is an apology an
investigation by uefa enough no i don't
think an apology is enough because
children like me are having nightmares
about this
and what they're going to do about that
and also
they should help people like me who got
affected by this
well thank you so much for speaking to
us
bye
across the world fyi is having big
conversations with those of you being
affected by big issues
it's a chance to have a say on how we
can all have a better future we call it
conversation take victoria for example
she wants the world of professional
ballet to be more inclusive for a
special report thomas flew to brazil to
meet with a ballerina inspiring millions
to embrace being different this is their
conversation
[Music]
this is santa rita
a small coffee plantation town
in the middle of nowhere
in brazil
[Music]
you wouldn't expect to find a celebrity
ballet dancer here
but vittorio bueno is making a name for
herself on social media
she's amazing among the best
despite being born without arms
victoria doesn't want to be labeled as a
disabled dancer
she wants to perform with a professional
ballet company like any other dancer
i'm in brazil to meet the girl inspiring
us all to embrace being different
and let nothing get in the way of our
dreams
[Music]
but vittoria faces an overwhelming fight
for the right to perform ballet without
arms
[Music]
victoria's feet do the things that hands
would normally do
[Music]
from the moment she was born she began
using her feet for everyday tasks
and by the age of five she had her heart
set on something else that many people
thought was impossible
victoria told her mum she wanted to be a
dancer
[Music]
victoria has won competitions for a
dance school and she came second in a tv
town contest
[Music]
i think kids even with arms wouldn't be
able to do as much as you can do so what
made you want to get into dancing
especially having no arms okinawa physio
for you what didn't make me give up was
the people who were always by my side
who supported me in all my decisions
especially when i decided i wanted to
dance
my teachers welcomed me from my first
experimental class
which gave me strength
but also joy
cinco says
[Music]
yes
two years ago i made the decision to
have my leg removed
it was growing in the wrong direction
so having a prosthetic leg has helped me
do all the things i couldn't do before
but victoria's disability could have
stopped her from doing everyday tasks
never mind achieving her dreams
she just simply hasn't let it and that
is amazing
so
when you go into the shops
do people stare
yeah they will stare at you yeah seeing
our customers
how did you do that
wow
yeah wow
one you're one more right now
thank you thanks ciao ciao
[Music]
is that you
yeah
my brother my mom and my
sister is that is that a bruise bruise
on your nose it was saying
i always especially at that age i used
to tap my nose on my forehead because i
would fall
oh so when you when you fell it made a
mark on your nose because you didn't
have the hands yeah i've fallen a lot
getting used to my leg i fell on my
hands but i've had a lot of falls so
i kind of get i kind of get what you
mean
wow
we all love watching you dance but what
do you get out of dance
el
salvador i feel very strong connection
to my body when i'm dancing
whether it be ballet jazz tap
i'm completely in the moment as if
nothing else matters
but despite vittoria proving she can do
anything dancers with arms can do
professional ballet companies she would
love to perform with say they do not
recruit disabled dancers for their
productions
i found out that there are some
specialist companies for disabled
dancers
but vittorio doesn't want that
she believes she should have the same
opportunity as any other dancer she
wants to audition for the world's main
ballet companies
[Music]
for now victoria's only audience is on
social media her video posts are
followed by nearly half a million people
[Music]
i will teach you some steps yeah why not
[Music]
ah
[Music]
victoria gets recognized a lot
[Music]
among her army of instagram followers is
a world famous professional ballet
dancer brazilian thiago solas
he was a principal performer for the
world famous royal ballet company in
london
thiago saugas has invited victoria to a
private dance lesson at a school in rio
de janeiro
[Music]
what does it mean to you to have a world
famous ballet dancer reach out to you on
instagram how long will there be
throughout this whole journey with dance
god is always putting people in my path
to help me my family friends and
teachers people like thiego soros
[Applause]
[Music]
thiago is teaching vittorio dance he is
created just for her and they will
perform it to a piece of music that is
special to him
[Music]
[Music]
it's a dream come true for me to meet
diego sores i was nervous and it's a
tense day but it is also the realization
of my dreams
i don't think i've met anyone who would
have the courage to do that not be
scared about what people think sing
if i can get into college i can keep
dancing and learning
and then i can inspire other people by
performing across the world
if that happens it will prove that
ballet can be more
[Music]
inclusive as their day together is due
to come to an end thiago suddenly
announces a surprise for vittorio
we're going to dance in a major theater
this is a surprise i've arranged for you
i hope you like it
thiago says he wants to show the world
just what inclusive ballet can look like
thiago and vittoria are going to perform
their dance at a major venue for ballet
rio city of arts theater
he's invited our cameras to film this
exclusive performance
for now this is the closest victoria
we'll get to performing professionally
with the world-renowned ballet dancer
[Music]
together they want to change the
thinking of many of the world's most
prestigious ballet companies
which for hundreds of years have seen no
place for disability
thiago's former company the royal ballet
says things are changing and they are
trying to make ballet inclusive
[Music]
victoria is more hopeful than ever that
she really can pursue her dream
for more conversations with kids
fighting for change head to our webpage
first dot news fyi and click on the link
[Music]
you